you don't get it literally they applied
to left maybe we move gotta go we gotta
go
remember only bring what you absolutely
cannot live without I know I know
you are everything
are you slow panicky 1% probably have
everything I need right let's go we're
never coming back
crap what is it I forgot something
you forgot something yes yes I told you
to double-check everything I know but
you rushed me I can't think straight
when you're rushing me on we're all
gonna come out no the only thing that
matters now is our lives but again and
if you go back there
you're gonna lose yours it's really
really really important and I need to go
back go
all right yeah I got it
now what mee maws family photo
collection you got me most photos and
sacrificed days the food and water we
can find more food in water but these
memories are priceless
hey hey hey remember remember me Mom was
the one to make you happy when you were
sad and me mom was the one to make you
dance when you didn't feel like dancing
and if we forgot this photo book Oh me
ma wouldn't forgive us fine just take
them whatever okay all right come on
let's go
[Music]
there's some things they're still
important to me do
No my box is gone so move my box
Sam wife the hell was this in the closet
with all the other shoes it's a shoebox
no this is my eraser collection erase
your collection don't remember when me
mo used to help me with my homework
she'd erase all my mistake collection
you mister like for a race that Galax
are you to decide what's important for
me
that's a racer question respite why look
this is stupid do be the racer still
work out just correct
all right you got your racers let's get
out of here delete let's go there's the
recipe for disaster
wait that should be me mas recipe book
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
my most famous recipe apple pie you said
you were gonna get the recipe boss he's
the apple pie it's so much better
finally that's mostly how is it home our
ball is so fresh did MIMO make it this
morning this morning
[Music]
I think this is our fourth or fifth time
filming with tanks and I have to say
it's easily the best experience we've
had so far
huge thanks the world thanks for
sponsoring this video the new mercenary
stuff they just came out with a bunch of
new maps new tanks tons of stuff all the
biggest overhauls for the game check it
out it's on consoles it's free and
there's a link in the description below
huge thanks guys thanks for watching